it is a sport with a big problem and now
big change
on a weekend when we reveal the review
of scottish cricket has identified
institutional racism the people at the
top of the game quit on mass
half a dozen directors resigned in
anticipation of the reviews
recommendations for change the board
said it wasn't a job they felt they
could do in the time skills required
kasim sheikh was one of two scottish
cricketers who prompted the independent
review when he and colleague majid hack
said they'd suffered racism throughout
their careers the lawyer for both men
welcomed the removal of the cricket
board but said it wasn't enough there
are individuals who were responsible for
racism who were responsible for the
exclusion and the discrimination that
took place over a period of years that
are in still in control when we look at
and compare and contrast the manner in
which white cricketers are treated and
the way that people of color asian black
are treated when it comes to display a
complete and utter difference you see
that in umpiring decisions you see that
in selections up and down this country
and you see that in the senior cultures
that exist within scotland
and that has to change once and for all
multiple referrals have been made by
investigators regarding alleged racist
behavior to different organizations
including police scotland this was a
weekend game at edinburgh south this
club doesn't have any record of racism
but players here recognize it as an
issue in the wider game
they should have done a thorough review
of who who was responsible for it
instead of the whole board stepping down
hopefully we will have some some order
to the things at some point of time when
everybody gets together and understands
that that this is a problem you know
when the new board is reinstated they
need to see that all
parties are equally representative
anti-racism campaigners make the point
that if you look at any grassroots game
in scotland there is huge participation
by non-whites but that changes as the
game tapers towards the top
they hope that changes now being made
will change that i think this will take
a very very long time to to eradicate
racism across the sport and in terms of
how that needs to be done in the process
but simply a lot of the people that have
suffered as part of this need to be
involved in that process the moment
there isn't the diversity across
committees and where decisions are made
these decisions and these impacts happen
to people and going forward they need to
involve the very people that have
suffered from this discrimination that's
the only way the sport is going to work
its way out of this in stepping down the
cricket board members apologize to
anyone who's experienced racism in the
game they describe this review as a
watershed moment for scottish sport and
society
in cricket at least their actions are a
game changer
james matthews sky news edinboro